what is the last big thing you purchased  my house first big thing you purchased  about my mama crazy lots of houses  what's up everybody I'm Taylor Brooks  here in South Beach with none other than  sink Juan Berkeley check and see if we  can get some fan love hey guys  alright so we are gonna ask you a  question and if you get it right your  merch is on us true or false  was I ever to look at here you're right  alright merch is on us show them outta  Bay it's simple you just tap Taylor  Brooks here taking you all around Miami  for the Superbowl beer at the bash a  gastropub hanging out with some of the  locals excited for the Superbowl right  okay let's pray true or false Miami  edition Miami on average is the warmest  us city in the winter  true it is true okay it looks like the  locals know their stuff so this one is  on me